Coffee on a Tuesday and blog 24 and to
everybody out there who's new welcome,
so there wasn't this Soviet astronomer
called Nikolai car and he devised a
system for measuring the energy needs of
a civilization on a very broad scale.
It's called the car dealership scale and
it breaks down like this.
A type one civilization is one that's
harness the full power of the planet on
which it lives,
which is to say a civilization that
utilizes all the solar,
wind,
nuclear,
etc.
Energy available to it on its home
planet.
This is mEasured using earth as an
example,
as 10 to the 16th was a type one.
Civilization can control the weather,
it can manipulate basic matter and its
economy is global.
Now,
a type two civilization is one that has
harnessed all the power from its nearest
store.
When the planet's energy output becomes
an equal to the needs of the
civilization,
that civilization will go right to the
source and devise some method for
collecting the energy from that giant
fusion reactor,
which is his parents start measured
using the son as an example,
as four times 10 to the 26th was a type
two.
Civilization is,
for all intents and purposes,
invincible.
there was nothing known to physics,
not even a super nova,
which can destroy it.
Now a type three civilization,
and this is where it gets cool is one
that has harnessed all the power of its
home galaxy,
which is to say all the many billions of
stars that comprise it,
sort of like the galactic republic from
star wars using our milky way as an
example.
this is measured at four times 10 to the
37th watts,
and then there's us human beings from
the planet earth.
We are drum roll please.
A Type zero civilization,
which means that we still get the
majority of our energy from dead plants.
How long will it take for us to become
type one?
Michio kaku,
a physicist who you might've seen on
every single science channel show has
pretty good that we'll get there
somewhere in the next 100 to 200 years
and type two and the next house and we
see the beginnings of that now,
but there's a problem here and it's,
it's out there in the stars in our
galaxy,
the milky way galaxy,
which has somewhere between 200 to 400
billion stars in it.
Common sense seems to tell us that there
has to be intelligent life out there
somewhere.
Most likely intelligent life,
which is way more advanced than us.
We know that any civilization type two
or above would have an energy signature
detectable by our instruments,
so the question has to be why don't we
see them?
There are many possible answers to this
question,
but the one I find most compelling is
the one most applicable to our situation
here on her.
Every intelligent species will go
through the process of discovering the
elements on the periodic table,
the work systematically from hydrogen on
up,
and eventually they'll come to
discovering element 92 known to us as
uranium.
This is a very special on earth that
appears in a few isotopes,
most commonly uranium two,
38.
Now this consists of 99 point two
percent of all the uranium that's out
there,
but there's also uranium 235.
Now this consists of point seven,
two percent of that's out there,
but it's much,
much more valuable.
See,
when you bombard uranium to 35 with a
free new truck,
you make uranium to 36,
a highly unstable adam,
so unstable that it has to split into
two lighter elements,
krypton and barium,
as well as three more free neutrons.
this process is called vision and it
releases a whole lot of energy.
How much energy?
Well,
there's a handy equation for figuring
that out.
It's simply the mass times the speed of
light square thing is.
It's very tricky to separate that
uranium 235 from the uranium 238 takes a
lot of time and a lot of money,
but if you can do it,
that remaining uranium to 35 is called
enriched uranium,
and if you have a good amount of it,
well then you've really hit the jackpot.
Remember those three free neutrons
coming off the original uranium to 36,
adam?
Well,
they're going to whiz away and bombard
other uranium 2:35
adams,
turning them into 2:36
is which then split apart again and
release three free neutrons each.
Now you can either control the speed of
this chain reaction if you want to
utilize the power of or something like a
city or you can just let the reaction go
as fast as it once and the result of
this
on earth.
Only the riChest and smartest countries
have been able to develop a nuclear
weapon because of the tediousness of
enriching uranium.
But just last month it was discovered
that the country of Iran has begun.
That process of enrichment and
successfully maybe many people want Iran
to stop enriching for fear that they're
building a bomb.
Iran says that's not what it's doing and
that it won't stop,
but people don't seem to believe them.
Though I don't have the slightest idea
why.
It's all very tense right now,
but let me.
Let me bring this back to my point.
See,
when an intelligent species learns to
enrich uranium element 92,
it all of a sudden gains the power to
totally destroy its own environment.
In other words,
to destroy itself.
Maybe this is the reason why we don't
see or hear from other intelligent life
in the cosmos.
Maybe it's because the most critical
time for any civilization is that
transition between type zero and type
one.
A type one civilization is global,
which means that its economy is global
as well as a large part of its culture.
It has to be tolerant,
communicative,
pluralistic.
It has to rise above the monocultural,
totalitarian,
often theistic belief in ultimate
conformity.
In other words,
it has to be peaceful.
We can see that though we possess a lot
of characteristics of a type one
civilization.
We're not quite there yet.
Totalitarianism still has it sanctuary.
It may very well be the case that there
are dozens of earth like planets out
there with extinct intelligent
civilizations.
Civilizations that failed to negotiate
that transition between type zero and
type one.
Civilizations caught up in their own
weaknesses and if we make it and one day
far from now are flying around the
galaxy and come across one that didn't.
There's no doubt to me that will feel
the profound a sense of pity because we
would know that with a little bit of
knowledge and empathy and courage,
it could've gone the other way.